Ric Bucher bleach report how you been
Rick I'm good how are you and Bravo
LeBron James thank you for bringing it
on thank you for bringing me on you bet
but how how refreshing is that to have
LeBron say I'm not going to react or
speak on something that I don't know the
full context of I can only say I
appreciate that he did that and I'm sure
that Kevin Durant appreciates that
because while it's fun for us or it's
whether it's entertaining for the public
and it's probably revenue producing for
us in the media there's something
inherently wrong when we have and it's
become not that not to get on a screen
here but I saw Rick it's what it's what
it's what's happened to us is like we
have things that are taken and
translated or transformed and they don't
do justice to the original content and
then something is said and you have this
whole audience out there that never seen
the original content and that's what
they are basing their reactions on and
and LeBron chose not to contribute to
that so I applaud him so let me get to
it then because I be honest with you
when I first heard the quote it is
provocative that is for sure yeah okay
and I was kind of trying to figure out
what is what is Durant saying so can you
sum up what Durant was saying based in
the context and provide if there is a
proper context that that folks lose when
they retell the story and recount his
quote Rick well I think there's a what
what Katy was saying is that there is
it's not just the media attention
he was specific in terms of the fan or
his in his words the fan boys in the
media the media that idolizes LeBron and
presents him in that light and that that
creates an environment and toxic uh you
know I don't know if that's the the
greatest word to use here it is a
pocket of word for sure but it creates
an atmosphere for any other player
coming into it that is uncomfortable
because now you are in the realm of a
person who is being perceived I'm being
presented as beyond reproach as
everything that he does is great and if
you're that the supporting cast or
you're the other superstar what that
ultimately means is if things aren't
great well it's not gonna be on LeBron
it's going to be on everybody else and
that I believe is the environment that
Kady was was referencing so I just look
I don't know how hard it would have been
and he says in the complete quote is
it's not LeBrons fault he says that
directly so he's not putting it on
LeBron he's putting it on this this
idolization of LeBron and the coverage
of him in that light that creates an
atmosphere that can be troublesome for
anybody else who decides to step into it
okay so then let's take it one piece at
a time here because him coming in Los
Angeles is a big thing I mean let's not
let's not kid each other here he is one
of the most famous athletes on the
planet into any sport absolutely you say
is the most famous American athlete and
that includes baseball and and a
National Football League and
internationally most famous American
athlete on planet Earth is LeBron James
coming to Los Angeles California to play
for the Tiffany franchise that is the
Los Angeles Lakers and then you look at
the 15 and 9 record and all the
statistics the only statistic of any
possible metric offensively or
defensively that LeBron James is not
leading for the Lakers right now is
blocked shots because that's JaVale
McGee okay so so when when you're
talking about the Lakers you have to
talk about LeBron James period end of
story why would that be viewed as
fanboying it's not it's not well and
that's something I don't yeah well this
is a greater context for me I don't
believe in Kady says elsewhere that you
know we're just play
basketball and I think if all the
questions were just about basketball
that he would have less of an issue with
it
but it has become because let's face it
I mean it's my my story got a huge huge
reaction in part because I had guys on
the record yeah but in large part
because it's about LeBron
it's about LeBron anything that you do
when it comes to LeBron he he has fed
our industry like no other athlete and
so now if you can get LeBrons thoughts
on anything on the planet that is going
to generate clicks why because that's
because what he has to say is important
or because he's so polarizing that
everybody just wants to know and so I
just believe that for KD and this is
part where I tend to agree with him we
don't need to ask LeBrons opinion on
everything yes it generates attention
yes it generates news yes it generates
cliques but can we have a modicum of
self-restraint as the media and not make
it as if everything needs to be put on
that plate because what happens is is
there is a residual that now that
whether you are commenting or not
commenting you're not looked at as and
in in the same light and and I will say
this when it comes to Kevin Durant I
also believe that this has a lot to do
with where he is in in his life in his
career in terms of he's still a single
guy as far as I know he's not in a
committed relationship he's just a young
single dude who wants to play ball and
if you present him an atmosphere that
interferes with that or looks like it
gets a little more complicated than that
then he doesn't want any of it if there
was there was another question I was
asking him just about about being in LA
or you know and that that aspect of it
and he said very quickly goes it doesn't
matter where we you know we have so much
money it doesn't matter where we live
that's not that's not an issue I was
thinking that's the that's the
opinion of a single guy you're married
if you have kids that's where you're
living where you're like all of that all
of that has an immense significance to
making a move and if he and if he like
certain furniture and he likes certain
things on the wall I mean what wait till
he's in a committed relationship that's
all gone to Rick I mean let's please as
soon as as soon as I met my wife to be
yeah we had she said she suggested that
we have a yard sale and I said great
because we had a lot of duplicate stuff
it was all my stuff that was in the well
Rick you know my wife Susie in my house
that is one chair one chair that I
brought into our relationship that still
exists that's it Wow no you don't care
no Rick do you cure bleach report here I
got a chair I got a I got a chip in a
chair in other here's another reason why
I think your story resonates okay is
because Durant is quoted on the record
and by the way kudos to him for doing
that and Durant's the one that I think
everybody in Los Angeles is hoping is
the guy that's gonna take that max
contract yeah and your headline why
doesn't anyone want to play with LeBron
anymore
plays exactly into the fear of the Laker
fan that LeBrons coming and he's not
gonna win here and the current roster is
not the one unless somebody
Lonzo or Kuzma or ingram or who knows
who is gonna blossom into that Jason
Tatum type talent to maybe be that Robin
to his Batman they're afraid that guy's
not there right now and if nobody's
coming it's not gonna happen and I think
that's played into everything certainly
if based on Durant's comments he's
definitely not the one coming yeah and
well I will say this I wouldn't I don't
think he's coming
and but I don't think he's coming for
other reasons and and it's that if and
when he leaves Golden State it will be
because he's never been given just
credit for what he's accomplished with
Golden State it will forever in some
people's minds and at least those that
have made themselves noticeable to him
there's an asterisk on there because it
was a championship team and he kind of
rode the coattails well he goes in plays
with LeBron he's he's facing the same
the same challenge I believe that when
if and when KD leaves and goes elsewhere
that he is going to join a team that
that needs him and that is building off
of him so that's that's the main reason
but yeah look it's it's not just and
here's the thing it's everybody one
immediately wants to point at the toxic
environment and that you know there's
this it's not just the media the media
and and the atmosphere around LeBron
that's created by his stardom and again
none of the players that I look by that
I spoke to begrudged LeBron for the
atmosphere that is around him it is a
function of just how big and powerful he
has become but it swallows its you know
it's a black hole it swallows everything
in its path and guys are aware of that
they've seen it swallow Kevin Love
they've seen it swallow Chris Bosh Kyrie
Irving was about to be swallowed he said
let me get to Boston because I think I
got a you know safe planet there guys
have seen that so now they're they're
worried about it
and so ultimately this is but it's not
just about the media it's about the guys
that are on the market Kawhi Leonard
Paul George last summer Kevin Durant
they're all similar if not identical to
LeBron as ball handling forwards who
aren't going to play off of another guy
they want to be at the at the heart of
the operation and at this stage do you
want to go knowing that well I'm not
going to be that I'm gonna be secondary
and all these guys are in the the prime
of their career do I want to sign up for
that at this point and who knows maybe
somebody goes the other direction we saw
Paul George make a decision everybody
thought he was going to the Lakers
ultimately he experienced something else
I I'm not going to predict ultimately
what happens I still believe that it's
more likely that the Lakers deal for
a young superstar or superstar that's
second to to LeBron than it is that they
acquire them through free agent all
rights and then before I let you go of
give me your best guess I know look
there's so much basketball to be played
between now and then right now we have
no idea what the Lakers are gonna look
like in april/may or you know the music
to their ears June I mean so what do you
give me your best guess Rick again cuz
well you know your headline is
provocative too why doesn't anyone want
to play with LeBron anymore as if that
is a fact right now on December right
six and and not that I need to tell you
this you don't right I know it was I
mean I put it out on Twitter it was the
Union yang of playing with LeBron yeah I
knew there was an upside a very powerful
upside and there's a but but there is a
downside to it and and and guy spoke to
it and and that was a big part of the
story but I honestly I'm not expecting
anything dramatic to happen with the
Lakers this season if anybody's thinking
that the Lakers now because they're 15
and 9 and they're in the midst of the
Western Conference playoff picture that
well okay let's strike while the iron is
hot let's go get another piece you know
suppose suppose if something jumps up
they'd make a deal but I don't I never
got the sense that that was the mindset
of the Lakers going into the season it
was we got LeBron let's retain our cap
space for next summer let's see which of
these young players fits with him with a
dynamic there and then we can make a
decision when if we have to deal with if
we have to if we have to trade for an
Anthony Davis say if that becomes a
possibility or some other star then we
know who we want to keep and who we
might be willing to let go but I just I
write for anybody who's thinking like
okay they're gonna they're gonna go for
it now I don't think that was ever the
plan and I don't know that there's
anything that's going to happen this
season that's going to change that Rick
thanks for the time appreciate it come
on in when you're when you're down near
the Lakers facility we're just up the
street in El Segundo
and I appreciate you you joining us on
on the story you got it you bet you bet
that's Ric Bucher the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience